[拍手]
30年前、夫と私は
ハワイに住んでいました。
サンジュは私のオトトデストラハワイを
馬鹿げた名前で呼んでいました。美しい故郷の後で幸せに暮らせることを期待されていたに違いありません。
鎮静剤の停止ですが、冒険を求め
て日本に移動し
ました。私の夫が日本で1年間過ごした大学生として、マホニーのあなたの標準を動機付けるためにどのエスタを呼び起こすかについて話し合います。
彼はジュネーブオクサナトキに戻りたいと強く望んでいました
。  da
cos theta Quattro Gatti
そのカナハニミドリは若いボガニーマスターと結びついています私
は山岳地帯に住むことに興味がありました
が、あなたが知っているスヴァは
急いでマスターをこっそり逃がすつもりなので、私
たちは長野で1年間だけ働くことにしまし
た あなたがそれぞれの名前を含んでいることをテストし
ましたそれは長野でしたか
私は私のものに触れて幸せでし
た1998年の長野冬季オリンピックの何年も前に
ハドソンがピカードでイガノを話していないと
非難しました
私たちが英語を教え
、フリーランスの翻訳者として働いてい
たのですが、それがあなたのエゴstat3ダンスであり
、長野のスタッフが親切以上に私たちを驚かせ
、雪国の文化
が魅力的だったことを受け入れた一人の男 しかし、エスター・ゲヴァ
・エレノアの娘サラ叔母アリシアは
統計的にダ・マッタ・ユウキくん
各商品チームでブームのカノーザ・バラストを知っています
私たちのステップは1年が経過
し、私の夫は信州大学イートン・アンガスに付属する中学校で教えるように頼まれました
彼女を夢見て、カズカ・チュガをそこに行かせ
たら、それは私が言っていることでした。
私のスナップは彼が喜んで
申し出を受け入れたので、私たちは滞在を延長
しました。
私は
ただもう一年は問題ないと思った
Otisrockyrockin II am
Watterson n dice over a karate master
少し私は何を失うのかわからなかった
が、それはトルコの息子でもない
osakiJamuna今は解体しないでくださいNewarkに行きます
okakiddoは今回私たちを蒸しました
私はアメリカ合衆国の永住権を失いました
waAmericaGas Co Co Co
私のグリーンカードを手放すために、
それは突然のさようなら
グリーンカドタノビコバは彼らが
私たちのものを選んでいたので私は
ハワイに戻って短い訪問をするつもりでし
た私はホノルル国際空港に到着したときにアトランティスを使って甘い計算をし
ました
sto-rox tae Kukでの入国審査で、正直なところ、
タタキの新しい料理人の狂気の料理は
単調すぎると役員はあなたが
過去2年間米国に住んでいない
と言いました
あなたのグリーンカードを降伏する
ODTJoanata WAグリーンカド
ホノルルは、私の目に湧き出る降伏の涙という言葉を聞いてエコノミストに与え
ます。ポータブルミニミスターを通して降伏します。
七面鳥ですが、ショーの名前はvini Navidad O'Connor stopですが、
これ
は起こり得ないと自分に言い聞かせましたが
、7月の降伏のアスラサーカスは、
すべての戦争映画の両方がカットされたものの1つでのみ聞こえるはずです。
ほとんどの人が私のものを撃ったと言って、
私が働いていた法律事務所に電話するべきだったが、私はあまりにも
邪魔されて、ライセンスされた模倣者について証明することを考えることができなかった。
Camryautomatic彼
はグリーンカードを放棄して彼らのものを送らなければなりません
グリーンカードああhocusrocotoそこに私
が米国になるチャンスがあります。 市民
マレーアメリカンエポキシ硬化は
私が所有する可能性に話しかけます委任されていません私は
罰せられて運命づけられたと感じましたそれはあなたが
最小限の
ココナッツを手に入れ
たものです ネガティブ私は皮肉な体を手に入れます
-良い一日のマスターIRAマイカ
マーティンソンは自発的に私の米国を降伏します
セントマーチンズナミカワミスターの永住権
。 カーネーションよDアメリカンウェイ
は彼女が私が降格され拒否されたと感じなければならないことを願って
いますがテスト可能ですあなたは
長いコガサがそこに出てケモジムを始め
たのを
知ってい
ますか 空港を降りた後、私は
アメリカで食べ物を取りませんか？私たちと一緒に来ませんでした
-そして、国内攻撃での損失にどのように対処しましたか？
当時GoogleforViceにインターネットを持ってい
なかったので、nodosainternetまたは
Amosand Estherparaqueセキュリティアドバイス今日のアメリカの
キマ送信物
同じような経験を持つ人は誰も知りませんでした
私
は過去を変えることができないという事実を受け入れて、私ができることをすることに移りました
CACO a Caroline
あなたがそこに着くと、彼らはそうする傾向がありませんでし
た-そして私
がしていたことの1つは 聖書だ
から、溶岩があなたがこれに行くことを示して
、私が出くわしたと言うようにとどまる
新約聖書の市民権について重要な何か
Sahadevageniusesmonopod a coccyxあなたは
後でスゴイがお金を手に入れましたそれは止まらないと
言いますが、私たちの市民権は天国
にあり
ます 私たちはチラーのiikeravaでもあり
ますが、それはあなたの先生が
これについて多くのことをしてくれたことを意味し、
私の本当の家がどこにあるのかを知っています。
米国市民権について警告しました
このパラメータShivaajugaamericanoは
zucchiniを調理
しました 今日、彼はあなたのスターターをたくさん所有していたと思うまで、私のものをプッシュしました私の
スナップは数年前に私の
夫が亡くなりました私は忙しい両親になりました
私たちの長男が
5歳のとき、私の夫は
長野光山として知られる長野工科大学で
お茶を飲むように
頼まれました。 地元
の人も海外の人も彼の英語の
授業に参加し
ていました。
susyvic angukのバイリンガルエンジニアが死んでいるのは
、あなたがエンジニアnorita.murphyの下に隠れていたということでは
ありませんが、あなたは立ち止まらなければなりません。
このソロタンクで私はやったが、それ
はイタリック体のAoE rocotoを持ち運ぶことさえ知っていた、
彼は私のものを手に入れなけれ
ばならない、英語の合体試験に行ってみませんか？
行くいいえシカカ
私がそのチェックアウトについてできることはすべて大丈夫な
ので、
ジメナを維持したり、ダコタにゲートが何をしたかを見るためにそれを許可しないでください
私はすぐに彼の提案にイエスと言いまし
たが、彼女は約 彼の
砂糖の高さで
あなたはそれがどのようにかかったかを知っています
私はいくつかの苦痛な経験をしませんでした
ええ彼は私が20歳のときに女神を連れ出すヤニックがこのことを言わなければなりません
私は
失敗しまし
た ビキニではないジハード
東京再びユニまたは東京で
何も悪いことをマスターする
ことはもうありません彼らはあなた自身を汚い話をしました
それは素晴らしい場所ですしかし私
はこれを見る私は賢明
ではなく自信過剰でした
彼らのドメインを切り抜けた死んだマシン
はこれに乗らない私がした
ことは練習なしでボクシングの試合に参加するようなもの
でしたが、それは
私がテレムンドをした機関があった場所でした私は
ノックダウンされ
て負傷しました それ
が広告だった何年も そこに行って、彼は
そこに行って、
28歳のときに止めました。もう一度テストを受けて敗北を終わらせたかっ
たので
、このあなたの夫について勉強するために新しい本を3冊購入しました。
そこについて
は、安全な家で道を示すことができない
と私は説明しましたが、失敗の恐れ
は非常に
大きかった
ので、彼が面白いように見えるものを刺したり撃ったりして、私はほとんどテストに行きませんでした
そこに色を塗る彼女はこれを終わらせる必要がない
ので、私の夫が
英語の試験のアイデアを思いついたとき、私は
彼らのために
行くのを嫌がりまし
た 失敗しても大丈夫
です。デニス
が窓の向こうにいるだけでした。トニー・カカロットがそれを手
に入れました。この姿勢で、あなたは
最終的に成功し、
英語を学ぶ他の人を助けることができ
ます。 前g  1つだけど、
ロックオンレッツゴーそれはあなたの有名な
写真仲間のギデオンですそれで私は
熟考するのに数日かかりましたそして私は
ついに私の研究の
目的が典型的に止まらないのを見ました
私は
子供
たちに、ノックダウンされたからといって、私たちが再び
立ち上がることができればノックアウトされたという意味ではないことを証明したかったのです
が、あなた
が彼らにその小さなスパイス
を呼んだらすぐに、
テキーラバーのこと船は夜まで保管されていなかった
ニューヨークオートショーミーステート
ああ私のスナップと私は私の
足音が
他の誰かの人生に違い
をもたらすことができると思った
私はエコエボポニーのリッキーに関する彼らのテレコムアナリストが
夜に一緒にやって来ます彼らは
私が35歳のときにケンの試験に合格したのでカサデがすでに道を譲っ
たそのビキニが好きではありませ
ん それ
同じ夏に刺された2人のキティのコサイン私
は何か新しくて
挑戦的なことを追求したので
、ビテッセシヴァ
サラのゲームがコネコだったことを知っていることに気づき
ました
長野の地方裁判所ですが、
他の2つは、私が答えたのですが
、Jotaの医師は完全に混乱する必要が
あり、翌年、私
は翻訳者と裁判所の通訳として働き
続け、英語の資格試験を続けました。
Jochen Ava
Sonny
ho ho ho did jana gana
a1 OK miss Coco OK to skip my step
私はTOEICテストを受けました。また
、ガイド通訳者になるための国家ライセンス試験に合格しまし
た。ガイド通訳者は
橋としての役割を果たす方法です。
金沢日本を経由して日本と世界を
行き来し、全国的な
アクアリオヘビの攻撃を
乗っ取ります。もっと多くの人が私に加わり、知識
を学び、共有する喜びを見つけてくれることを
願っています。  f日本の歴史と
文化、そして英語や
他の外国語を話すことは、
古くからの
素敵なメモを破壊します。
ああああ
私のマス米国 グリーンカードは私を去りましたが
、私が勉強し、私の最高の素晴らしい機会になることを学び続ける
につれて、アメリカーノグリーンカードは来ましたが、アイスキュロスはギバーストップスコシーで
はありませ
ん 私のスナップは波のように来続け
ます現在のナミレオーネは今日です私たちのTEDxの経験
はそれらの1つです
これで
トニーカクを学び続け
てください私の時間は立ち止まって
、私たちの前に転がる大きな波を逃さない
ようにすることですので、滞在してください、しかしそれは
あなたがオークランドに行かない最小化です
そして私はあなたが私の仕事に感謝しています あなた
[拍手]